diejenigen die brüllen die brüllend
ihnen an diesem wochenende ganz viel
hass entgegen und diese stimmen diese
menschen die zu tausenden auf die straße
gegangen sind am wochenende die sind
ganz offenbar eben auch ein teil
deutschlands an diesem wochenende
gewesen und wir wir schämen uns für
diese bilder das darf ich ihnen sagen
herr botschafter die sich hier vor allen
dingen auch in berlin abgespielt haben
am wochenende
was sind ihre gedanken gewesen nicht nur
als botschafter sondern als mensch als
sie diese bilder wie wir sie hier sehen
von dieser großkundgebung am gestrigen
samstag in berlin gesehen haben das ist
verstörend diese bilder zu sehen und es
gab auch unglaublich antisemitische
bemerkungen die dort gegrillt worden
sind dass wurden flaggen verbrannt und
synagogen angegriffen und das hat nichts
mit dieser krise zu tun
diese krise hat nichts zu tun mit der
deutschen im jüdischen gemeinschaft und
ich verurteile jeden angriff auf die
deutsche jüdische gemeinde dieser
antisemitischen ausschreitungen ich muss
sagen allerdings dass auch die deutschen
politischen führungsetagen also in
präsident steinmeier die kanzlerin und
andere sehr sehr eindeutig diese
anpassung der botschafter denn diese
demonstration sind nicht verhindert
worden es gab gestern die
großdemonstration und am nachmittag
heute am heutigen sonntag ist wieder ein
zug hier wenige hundert meter von hier
entfernt in berlin durch kreuzberg durch
mitte gezogen mit denselben parolen und
wieder hass gegen israel ist wurde
skandiert hier direkt vor der haustür
quasi tel aviv bombardieren das heißt
was sind diese worte der politik wert
wenn dann gleichzeitig genau das wieder
auf deutschlands straßen passiert
zunächst einmal denke ich sollten sie
nicht vergessen dass es auch
demonstrationen gab bei denen oder
unterstützung israels ausgedrückten oder
das ist nicht nur ein großer meinungs-
block in deutschland der
eindeutig antisemitisch wäre und wie ich
gesagt habe gab es große und eindeutige
reaktionen der deutschen politischen
führung auf diese phänomene aber es gab
eben wie gesagt auch demonstrationen in
berlin frankfurt leipzig die solidarisch
mit israel waren auch am freitagabend
gab es solidaritätsbekundungen mit der
justizminister mit mit der vorsitzenden
der grünen partei annalena baerbock die
sehr eindeutig und unzweideutig ihre
unterstützung für israel formuliert hat
das heißt ich verwerfe das nicht dass es
hier probleme mit antisemitismus geht
das sollte auch ganz klar verurteilt
werden und zwar genauso wie auch der
abschuss von 3100 raketen auf israel
klar verurteilt werden musste ich glaube
aus diesem standpunkt ist es so dass die
masse der deutschen förderung an unserer
seite steht dieser antisemitismus nicht
besonders besorgniserregend wie wir ihn
jetzt diesen diesen tagen erlebt haben
sie sagen der muss klar verurteilt
werden aber wir brauchen ein rezept
dagegen in deutschland was wir machen
mit diesem antisemitismus offenbar haben
wir keine lösung gefunden damit
umzugehen und das ist etwas was jetzt
nicht nur in den vergangenen tagen
entdeckt worden ist das ist etwas das
traurigerweise schon viele jahre wenn
nicht sogar jahrhunderte in europa
verwurzelt war
und es ist offensichtlich nicht so
einfach dann einfach zu sagen dass man
jemanden verhaftet und dass das problem
damit beendet wäre
die die antwort findet sich in bildung
und auch in den bildungsinstituten
höheren bildung religiöse institutionen
kulturelle institutionen müssen hier
eine rolle spielt kinder lernen nicht
nur in der schule sondern auch zu hause
und deswegen ist es ebenso wichtig
darauf hinzuweisen dass kinder natürlich
die erziehung brauchen aber auch deren
eltern
das ist also ein sehr breiter
anstrengung die man unternehmens und man
braucht auch ganz klare gesetzliche
vorgaben die auch umgesetzt werden wenn
menschen diese linie überschreiten denn
viele die dort demonstriert haben
neben demonstrierten das ist ganz normal
in demokratien dass man friedlich
demonstrieren davon das passiert
natürlich auch in israel aber wenn sie
eine gewisse linie überschreiten wenn es
gewalttätig wird menschen auf ein
antisemitisch wird dann braucht ist klar
er hat bombardier in tel aviv
bombardieren
keine friedliche wenn man das kandiert
ist es keine friedliche demonstration
mehr
dazu reicht nicht es sind keine flaschen
fliegen dazu müssen keine steine fliegen
da stimme ich ihnen natürlich über alle
zahlen die ja herr botschafter es gilt
heute als friedliche demonstration was
heute hier vor der tür in berlin
passiert ist da lief die polizei ganz
friedlich nebenher aber es wurde eben
skandiert israels und tel aviv
bombardieren
es gilt als friedliche demonstration
wissen sie ich habe auch mit
sicherheitsbeauftragten gesprochen die
mich kontaktiert haben und sie haben mir
versichert dass sie alles tun werden und
diese phänomene zu unterbinden und diese
art von demonstrationen die auch
gewalttätig sind und hasserfüllt sind
unterbunden werden sollen wo zum
beispiel israelische flaggen verbreitung
wäre und ich nehme sie beim wort und ich
hoffe dass wir weiter diese
anstrengungen unternommen werden um das
zu verhindern werden sie in der lage
sein alles zu verändern das weiß ich
nicht aber wir sollten hier eine gewisse
erwartungen haben das ist also wirklich
größere anstrengungen gibt um diese
phänomen entgegen zu treten
diese art von hass auch zu unterbinden
herr botschafter für das gespräch wir
werden alles tun dass israelis und juden
hier in diesem land nicht in angst leben
müssen und ich wünsche ihnen dass sie
schon bald vor allen dingen familien und
kinder in ihrem land nicht mehr diesem
dauerbeschuss aus dem gaza-streifen
seitens der hamas ausgesetzt sind und
diese angst ja bald möglicherweise
wieder sich legen würde ich dagegen hat
sich für das gespräch heute abend und
wir wollen einmal bei hamburg lange über
die demonstration bereits gesprochen wir
wollen noch einmal schauen was am
wochenende und zwar in ganz deutschland
los war in den straßen welche
dimensionen diese antisemitischen
proteste auf unseren straßen in
deutschland angenommen haben vor allem
den gestern deutschland an diesem
samstagnachmittag
israel hass judenhass köln
rund 800 menschen demonstrieren gegen
israel
es wird versucht eine israel flagge
anzuzünden die polizei muss den hass
protest auf
ähnliche bilder zur selben zeit in
frankfurt
[Musik]
bochum menschen skandieren wir werden
nach jerusalem marschieren
[Musik]
berlin in der hauptstadt gleich 1500
menschen palästinenserflaggen tel aviv
bombardieren wird gerufen kindermörder
israel und inmitten dieser hetze kinder
flaschen fliegen böller werden gezündet
die polizei löst die eskalierende demo
auf sie muss tränengas einsetzten
fast 100 polizisten werden verletzt
und heute ging es weiter mit all dem
hass bilder wenige meter von unserem
studio entfernt wieder mehrere hundert
menschen mit offenem hass gegen israel
[Musik]